the house select committee investigating
the assault on the capitol will question
a key witness today pastor bologna who
was former president trump's white house
counsel on january 6 will deliver
videotape testimony behind closed doors
officials say he could tell the
committee more about trump's inner
circle and what they were doing before
during and after the capitol riot scott
mcfarland has the story
the january 6 select committee believes
former white house counsel pat cipolloni
has exclusive insights into what then
president trump did or didn't do as his
supporters attacked the capitol how
important an interview is this for the
committee i think it's important for the
committee i mean mr sipoloni was in the
room uh he
we have testimony from others about what
he said and did simpoloni appeared
informally before the committee in april
but for weeks there's been pressure for
him to testify on the record vice chair
liz chaney used social media to do so
and called him out by name our committee
is certain that donald trump does not
want mr sipoloni to testify here the
committee then took it to the next level
and issued a subpoena just 24 hours
after former white house aide cassidy
hutchinson's blockbuster testimony in
which she said sipoloni warned of
criminal exposure if trump went to the
capitol january 6. mr cipolloni said
something to the effect of
please make sure we don't go up to the
capitol cassidy keep in touch with me
we're going to get charged with every
crime imaginable
the committee will likely press
sipolonium whether he gave the same
advice directly to trump and whether the
then president pushed to go to the
capitol anyway the panel may have to
navigate certain privileged claims but
says there are many questions simploni
should be able to answer there can be
a an assertion of attorney-client
privilege but remember he represents the
presidency not donald trump the man
today's interview comes four days ahead
of the committee's next public hearing
which cbs news has learned will focus on
the mobilization of the mob including by
far-right groups and domestic violent
extremists tony
scott thank you very much